Я дуже довго не був у
школі, тим паче на уроці.
І прийшов, кажуть: «Ну,
англійська мова». Ну окей.
І я дуже вдячна моїй мамі, яка мене
колись віддала із, там, з 5-ти років уже
на мінімальні такі курси англійської мови.
І я, насправді, полюбила мову цю.
І вона у мене, в принципі,
в раціоні вживається,
але є моменти, які можна підтягувати.
Hello, guys! It’s time for English lesson.
My name is Nataliia Liashko. Let’s start!
And I would like to see my guests today.
So, hello, Alina! Hello, Alex!
Alex, how are you today?
- I'm well, thank you. And you?
- I'm fantastic. Thank you very
much. What about you, Alina?
- I'm okay, thank you.
- You're okay, it’d good.
Let’s start the lesson.
Today we are going to continue talking
about transport and we’ll add directions.
Giving directions, okay?
Let’s start with our homework.
I asked you to rank the means of
transport from the slowest to the fastest.
Okay, let’s just briefly discuss.
What do you think is the slowest?
- I think tram is the slowest.
- Amazing. Thank you very much.
Alina, would you like to add something?
- To talk about the slowest or
to say what is after the tram?
- You decide.
- I think bus can be pretty slow too.
- Okay. This is really good.
Okay, what's next after tram,
bus? What's going to be next?
- I think next one – ship.
- Yeah.
- Okay, agree?
- Agree. For sure.
- And what do you think
is the fastest? The top?
- The plane?
- Plane. Or helicopter?
- No, plane.
- Plane.
- For sure?
- For sure. Or it can be these Japanese
trains, which are going super-fast.
- Super-fast, okay.
So, this can be possible.
We have just train, a typical train.
I don’t think this is super-fast. I
would agree with plane. Okay?
- Yeah.
- What do you think? Tell us.
Let’s move on. How can I get from… to…?
So, let’s have a look at the picture.
We have railway station, a park,
cinema, tunnel, Jake’s house.
So, we are talking
about Jake in a moment.
And supermarket. Any
unknown words for you?
- I understand.
- Okay, so, just an example.
I'm just checking you, okay?
How can I get from the supermarket
to the cinema? Can you help me?
- With which transport
you can get – you ask us?
- We don’t use transport here,
no transport on the picture.
I think these words can help you.
- Okay.
- So, from the supermarket to
the cinema – how can you get?
- So, can I, please?
- Yes.
- So, you walk through King Street
and after you turn to the right.
- Okay.
- You are going through the bridge.
And on the right side
you will see the cinema.
- The cinema. That was a really nice
answer, thank you very much, Alina!
Okay, now we’ll focus on prepositions.
And we’ll come back to this a bit later.
So, grammar time! Do you like grammar?
- So-so…
- Let’s do it…
- A lot of people say like Alex.
No, we don’t like grammar.
Let’s try. Okay? It can
be difficult but let’s try.
Maybe it’s gonna be easy for you.
So, Prepositions of Movement. Let’s start
with number 1 – to.
Repeat after me – to.
- To.
- Into.
- Onto.
- Across.
- Along.
- Out of.
- Over.
- And through.
- through.
- So, if you look at the pictures,
over – if you have a bridge –
what will you use with the
bridge? Through or over?
- Probably, it can be
over. Better than through.
Yeah, so, I made a mistake.
- It’s okay, it was just…
We can use it in the lesson.
We test the students, then
we give them information,
then we test them again.
It’s okay, it’s not a mistake.
So, out of – this means
that you leave something - З.
Okay. Onto – on top. Into – inside.
- Inside.
- Yes. Okay, across – через,
тобто across the street.
Along – вздовж. So, along
the street or across the street.
It depends. Через дорогу
чи уздовж дороги. Okay?
Now, let’s remember these prepositions.
So, look at the words and I give
you 1, 2, 3 and you talk with me.
We name them one by one.
1, 2, 3!
To, into, onto, across,
along, out of, over, through.
Continue. To, into, onto, across,
Good. To, into, onto, across,
along, out of…
over, through… Through!
Okay, it’s gonna be more challenging. To,
into, onto, across, along,
out of. Bravo!
- … we just said it!
- Along?
- No.
- Over.
- Over! Through.
- Good. To, into, onto,
across, along, out of…
- Over!
- Yes, amazing!
- Through.
- Bravo!
- Let’s remember.
- To, into, onto, across, along,
out of, over, through.
- Amazing!
- To, into, onto, across, along,
out of, over, through.
- Okay. Alina, can you try?
- To, into, onto, across,
along, out of, over, through.
- Bravo. Alex, your turn.
- To, into, onto, across,
along, out of, over, through.
- Fantastic! That was amazing,
wasn’t it? So, let’s move on.
We have the prepositions
for you to remember.
But I'm sure you know them
all. And we have 5 sentences.
So, we need to choose the correct
preposition. Let’s go with number
1: Dad is putting sausages
onto or into the barbecue?
- Into the barbecue… Or
no – onto the barbecue!
- Yes! Actually, when we have
a barbecue, we put them onto.
Number 2: She is swimming
across or over the river?
- Across the river? Or no…
- Over the river?
- Over the river or across?
- No-no, across.
- Swimming across.
- Yes, across the river. Number 3:
The children are diving
into or along the sea. Diving.
- Into?
- Yes, correct. Number 4:
she is coming through
or out of the theatre now?
- Out of the theatre.
- Yes. And number 5:
Look! He is jumping
out of or over the fence?
Do you know the word “fence”? Паркан.
- Yeah but we are thinking… over.
- Over?
- Over. Yes, agree. Over the fence.
Well done! Now, let’s
have a look at this text.
Jake is giving his friend directions
to his new house. And this is his text.
When you come out of the
station, turn right. So, he is here.
Exit and leave the railway
station. And walk … King Street.
What is going to be there?
- Walk across the…
- These words can help you.
Once we already used out of. Okay?
- Along?
- Along? Alina, do you agree?
- Do you remember what is along?
- Yes.
- What is it?
- Вздовж.
- Вздовж. So, let’s see
how is it. Along… Yes!
- Correct. So, you leave the railway
station. Walk along King Street.
- Yes.
- Turn left on the River
Road. Yeah? And go?
- … the bridge.
- Over?
- Over the bridge, bravo! We’re
already here. Walk … the tunnel.
- Through.
- Bravo, through the tunnel,
you are here. Get … of the tunnel.
- Get along?
- Вийти з тунелю.
- Out of?
- Yes. And until you get to
the Pane Lane, you are here.
- Walk across.
- Walk across. And my house is
right in front of you at number 12.
Easy! Right?
- You can miss it… Cool.
- Yes! You can’t miss it.
It’s very easy to reach it.
So, a task for you. Ready?
Choose the correct preposition. Number 1?
- John is walking across the road.
- Good, across the road. Number 2?
- Over… He is going over the river.
- Good. And number 3?
- He is going through a tunnel.
- And number 4?
- He is going out of the house.
- Let’s check. He is going…
- Into.
- Into because there is
an arrow, have a look. Into.
- Ah, into the house.
- He is going inside. The door
opens and he comes into. Okay?
- Let’s move on. I suggest
you to play a game. Let’s play?
- Let’s play.
- We love playing games. You showed us.
This time we are going to
play with a dice. This is the dice.
And I want you to give me
examples with the preposition.
So, number one… If I roll
the dice and I have number 1,
you tell me “over”. Over a what?
Over the fence, over the bridge.
So, you give me an example.
Okay? Like this. Just for you
to remember. For example:
I have 4 and you tell me
for along. Along the street.
Along the river, for example.
It depends. So, ready?
Who will start first? Alex or Alina?
- Okay, me.
- Alina.
- But I'm a bit worried.
- Don’t worry, no stress.
So, I roll the dice and 3,
this is 3.
- Across. I'm walking across the river.
- Bravo, one point to
you. Alex, ready? And 2.
- Through the tunnel.
- Yes. Can you walk through the
tunnel or you go through the tunnel,
or you drive through the tunnel?
- I drive…
- Drive, fantastic. Okay,
Alina, it’s your turn.
I roll the dice. 6.
- Into. She's coming into the cinema.
- Okay, possible. So,
Alex, your turn.
6 again.
- She is going into the house.
- Bravo. 2-2. Let’s try
again one more time?
- Yeah.
- Okay. So, Alina, for you. It’s 2.
- Through. She is going through this pain.
- Okay. Dramatic. Drama, total drama.
Alex, 5.
- She's going to school.
- Good, possible. So, it’s
3-3. Again, it’s? We call it a…
- Draw!
- Bravo.
- Bravo, well done. Let’s move on.
So, we come back to this, remember?
- Yeah.
- And can you help me now to get
from the supermarket to the cinema?
Let’s try with Alina.
- Okay. You're walking
across the King Street.
Turning to the right and
going over the bridge.
And after you turn to the right and then
you gonna see the building with a cinema.
- Fantastic, thank you very
much! Let’s try with Alex.
- Ого.
- So, I'm at the cinema and I need to
go to the Jake’s house. Help me please.
- You must enter the cinema,
then you must through the tunnel…
- Go.
- Go through the tunnel.
Next you must across railroad.
- Pane. Pane Lane.
- Pane lane and…
- You're there.
- You are there.
- Yes, Jake’s house is there.
Fantastic, thank you very much!
Now it’s quiz time. I'm gonna check you.
So: Walk over the bridge. Correct?
- Correct!
- Yes, correct. What about this one:
Turn left and walk across the tunnel.
- No.
- No, it’s false.
- It’s false.
- Because we cannot
walk across the tunnel.
- Thank you, Alex. Through
the tunnel, okay? And one more:
Get out of the tunnel
and walk into the road.
- Into the road is not correct.
- Into the road, it’s not
correct. What's the problem?
- Over?
- No-no, across.
- So, there are two parts here.
Get out of the tunnel, is this…
- It’s right, it’s correct.
- And the second one?
- And walk through the road.
- Over?
- Across… Over…
- You just mentioned this word.
- Across?
- Yes. Across the road. You cross the
road and you go across the road. Bravo.
Thank you very much. And one more task,
just to remember all the prepositions.
Who will be faster? Let’s start with
Alina and Alex, okay? Alina, ready?
- To, into, onto, across…
Is it across?
- Yes.
- Across, yes.
Over… no, over is after. I
always don’t remember this one.
- It also starts with A.
- Yeah, across and along.
- Yes.
- Okay, along.
Get out? No-no, out of! Over and through.
- Amazing! Thank you very
much. Alex, can you do it faster?
- Maybe.
- Let’s try.
- To, into, onto, across, along,
out of, over, through.
- Yay!
- Amazing. That was
really nice. And we check.
- … Across, along, out
of, over. Along and out of.
- Everything is correct. Along and
out of – these are confusing for you?
- Yeah, I'm bugging there.
- Yeah, probably just the
pictures. Out of – just out of the box.
Think out of the box.
- Yeah, out of the box! And
I always want to say get off.
- Yes, sometimes it happens.
But when we talk about movement -
out of the box – this is for you the
trigger word. And along the street.
- Along the street.
- Yes. So, your homework. You
are organizing a party at your house.
Write a paragraph, give directions
from the nearest metro or
bus station to your house.
And draw a simple map. Okay?
- Okay.
- There is a bell. Unfortunately, we have
to stop the lesson. Thank you very much!
- Thank you.
- Thank you, Nataliia!
- See you next time!
- Всі ми колись хотіли,
навпаки, звільнитися від цього.
Тому що це – 11 років ми вчилися,
в нас намагалися вштрикнути всі ці
знання, які ми так тяжко приймали.
Ну, я скажу, що зараз десь я би
хотіла мати знову змогу вчитися.
Сидіти і поглинати знання.
Тому що, в кінці кінців, як мій
батько казав: «Це пригодилося».
Будем пробувати. Сподобалось. Дуже
класна вчителька і все так пояснювала.
Технології! Мене
вразили технології. Дошка,
пультиком там воно щось
переключалось, все так цікаво було.
Комунікація просто
на фантастичному рівні.